А це в нас будуть млинці з червоною рибою і сиром.
Дуже чисто та апетитно.
Так виглядало воно. Переробили все. Нічого не лишилося. Тільки вікно фасадне.
За їхніми спинами - черга… Тільки зліпили вареники - їх одразу ж розбирають.
У Нойсі, що неподалік Дюссельдорфа на північному заході Німеччини,
українці відкрили продовольчу крамницю, де можна купити вареники,
голубці, сирники, млинці та інші українські страви з різноманітними начинками.
Придбати ці продукти, щось схоже - пельмені, вареники, було можливо
тільки в російських магазинах. Враховуючи тепер наші відносини з Росією,
відповідно рука не піднімалася туди йти і лишати там кошти.
І виникла ідея створити, по-перше, робочі місця для наших дівчат,
які тут, які приїхали без знання мови, бар’єри психологічні і мовні бар’єри.
Дуже важко було їм знайти роботу. Мені здалося, що це як одна з візій компанії
- це працевлаштування наших. Друге - це було питання заповнити нішу,
якої немає, а клієнти на даному етапі з’явилися.
Тільки в одній Німеччині перебуває мільйон наших українців, які вимушено переїхали.
Персонал повністю український. Лише на касі дівчина з Литви,
яка вільно говорить німецькою, щоб пояснювати німцям особливості української кухні.
Загалом восьмеро людей. Усі оформлені офіційно, запевняють, що зарплати гідні.
Оксана Мілько до кулінарії взагалі ніякого відношення не має.
Вона за фахом - біохімік. До війни працювала в лабораторії при лікарні у Балаклії
на Харківщині, а мешкала у сусідньому селищі Пришиб.
Ми приїхали, тому що вже сил не було терпіти.
Обстрілювали село протягом 6 місяців щодня.
Тому діватися вже не було куди, коли наші почали наступати,
бої, інтенсифікація пішла, і ми вимушені були тікати.
Оксана та її мама виїхали з України два місяці тому. Каже, як і чимало інших українців,
не звикли просто сидіти вдома і знайшли роботу через інтернет
на сайті з оголошеннями про вакансії.
Ми не одразу виїхали в Німеччину. Ми спочатку виїхали в Польщу
і там ми теж не ставали на облік як біженці. Ми з матір’ю одразу пішли
працювати на завод, тому що потрібно було чимось зайняти мізки,
а не сидіти кожен день й читати новини. Так з ґлузду можна зійти,
тому ми вирішили працювати. І якраз така механічна робота,
такі процеси відволікають. Воно затягує, і ти менше думаєш
про все це жахіття, яке нині твориться в Україні.
Ця, на перший погляд, монотонна робота - своєрідна психотерапія
для біженців з України. А з іншого боку - своєрідне шоу для перехожих.
Люди зупиняються, роздивляються, фотографують.
Для місцевих це щось незвичне й оригінальне - магія створення вареників зачаровує.
Місцева жителька Генрієтте ще ніколи не куштувала українських страв.
Вона замовила вареники з вишнею і сиром.
Я купую - сподіваюся, що правильно вимовляю - вареники.
Я живу неподалік, побачила це, а також прочитала в газеті, що тут українські страви.
Ми багато робимо, зокрема у Дюссельдорфі, для українських біженців
і, звісно, треба спробувати цю їжу. Я не дуже знаю, що це таке, але потім ще почитаю.
Вареники з картоплею коштують 7 євро за кілограм. За німецькими мірками
це недорого - приблизно, як два пива.
Вареники з капустою і грибами - 8 євро. А голубці зі свинини та яловичини - 13 євро.
Сирники класичні - 11 євро. Також є пельмені, хінкалі та інші страви.
- Треба було ж одружитися на одеситці, щоб купувати це все в магазині!
- А що таке? Дівчата зробили. Сказали, що смачно!
Оксана родом з Одеси. Живе у сусідньому Дюссельдорфі.
Крамниця лише декілька днів, як відчинилася, а сарафанне радіо вже працює.
Наша подруга дізналася, а їй сказав Саша - податковий радник,
тобто він сказав, і передали далі й далі. А ми тепер будемо теж далі передавати.
Шеф-кухар "ГастроОми" Олександр Данканич здобув освіту в Англії,
де вивчав класичну французьку кухню, а зараз готує українську в Німеччині.
Йому сподобалася ідея Дениса поширити український дух і смак у Німеччині.
Я починав з рецептів бабусі, але скажу чесно - не своєї, а колеги.
Він казав, що вона робить чудові вареники. Починали з тіста, яке було шикарне,
і начинки так само. Але потім виявилося так, що коли ми перейшли
на професійну велику кухню, то рецепти перестали працювати так,
як у домашніх умовах. Напевно, через те, що коли це тісто місить тепла рука
і коли це місить тістомашинка в нашому випадку, бо ми на такий об’єм вручну
саме тісто вимісити не зможемо. То по-іншому запускаються процеси
і нам потрібно було то все, як-то кажуть, відробляти швидко,
щоб ми могли підготувати хороший рецепт до запуску вже.
Основа меню - українська класика. А саме - вареники у різних варіаціях
з додаванням душі, хисту та досвіду, як каже сам Олександр.
З некласичних начинок - вареники з малиною і сиром.
Загалом 34 позиції у меню на даний момент.
Різні начинки, різновиди таких страв як налисники, деруни.
У нас є звичайні картопляні, з цукіні дуже смачні. Багато навіть колег на кухні
ніколи не пробували і сказали, що дуже цікава ідея, дуже цікавий рецепт.
Сподіваюся, що нашим покупцям воно теж дуже зайде. Я завжди синхронізувався
з продуктами, які я роблю. Я їх відчував і тому коли я розробляв рецепт
чи сирників, чи якоїсь начинки - це в мене трохи як медитативний стан,
в який я вхожу. Я починаю відчувати консистенцію. Я, як кажуть,
вкладаю свою душу, щоб вона відображалася в тому рецепті.
А це обговорюють новий рецепт. Знімати близько не можна.
Додай трохи води… Чисто сто грамів води додай і далі йдемо по рецепту…
А що далі по рецепту - говорити і показувати не можна. Авторське право. Смачна таємниця.
А от власне поява українського продовольчого магазину вже не таємниця.
Про "ГастроОму" з позитивним відгуком написала місцева газета.
Стаття називається "Як троє українців знайомлять з батьківщиною".
Крім того, українська крамниця вже інтегрована у місцевий харчовий ланцюжок.
Працюємо з локальними фермерами. Відбираємо перець, капусту - все особисто.
Шеф-повар їде на поле, на склади фермера, відбирає.
Намагаємося використовувати тільки якісні продукти.
У приміщенні, де тепер українські страви, раніше торгували пончиками, а потім була бургерна.
Так виглядало воно. Переробили все. Нічого не лишилося. Тільки вікно фасадне.
Все решта було змінено. Плитка, стіни, кухня. Все було під нуль знесено,
все було зроблено з чистого листа.
Назвалися "GastroOma", тобто "гастрономічна бабуся", бо передбачають,
що основні клієнти будуть все ж таки не українські біженці, а німці,
які мають хороший дохід і готові витрачати свої кошти на ручну роботу
та якісні смачні продукти. Німецькі бабусі українську "гастрономічну бабусю" вже оцінили.
Подивись, що в мене тут є. Як чудово! Прекрасно! Ще й купон на скидку.
- Що ви купили? - Я це купила - деруни з цукіні. Ммммм…
Я маю вже швидко додому йти, поки вони не розтанули. Мої українські гості будуть точно раді.
Серед тих, хто ліпить вареники, і військовий пенсіонер Віталій з Миколаєва.
Він був змушений виїхати через півтора місяця після початку війни.
Спершу в Хорватію, а потім у Німеччину.
Працювати в жіночому колективі йому подобається.
Каже: дівчата не стільки роблять зауваження, скільки дають поради.
Вареник зліпити ось тут треба сильніше, щоб він не розвалювався.
Тобто ось такі нюанси, зауваження, на що треба звернути увагу.
Не те, що зауваження: "Що ти там не так, а це ось так!"
А просто люди підказують, в кого є який досвід господині вдома,
чи людина працювала на такому виробництві, то, звісно, знає,
як це у промисловому масштабі робити.
Віталій працює у сімейному дуеті. У його дружини Ольги сьогодні перший робочий день.
Подивіться, він там добре затискає? - Добре.
- Його коронне блюдо яке? - Його? Борщ!
- Борщ і макарони по-флотськи. Це, я так думаю, моя найбільш козирна страва
- макарони по-флотськи. Я був в Італії, ходив-купував, сказали, що з м’ясом
- макарони паста болоньєзе. Я довго в цих макаронах шукав м'ясо…
Справа в тому, що коли я роблю, то в мене у фарші треба ще пошукати макарони.
Це мені більше подобається, з різноманітною піджаркою, я роблю це значно смачніше.
Щоб відкрити такий заклад у Німеччині, Денису та його колегам знадобилося пів року.
Спеціально взяли приміщення, де раніше теж була гастрономія,
щоб було легше з різними бюрократичними дозволами.
Якщо воно не було адаптовано перед цим на гастрономію, відповідно
це мінімум 8-12 місяців пройти всі етапи покроково в Німеччині, щоб це все зробити.
Бізнес-план, дизайн, візуалізація, розробка бренду й логотипу,
розробка рецептури - все це вже позаду. Було нелегко, зізнається Денис,
бо мета - вгодити не лише українцям, а й німцям, туркам та іншим діаспорам,
які живуть у Німеччині. Тож роблять і бургерні котлети, і шніцелі.
Працюють лише декілька днів і збирають відгуки, чого не вистачає,
хто з якою начинкою і що саме полюбляє.
Денис також створив своєрідний ланцюжок взаємодопомоги
не лише для українських біженців за кордоном,
а й для внутрішніх переселенців у самій Україні.
Ці глечики для нашого декору передавалися з України.
В Німеччині ми не змогли таке знайти, а якщо навіть на Ібей чи Амазоні,
то воно коштує тут дуже дорого. Воно вироблялося в Слов’янську.
Коли почалася війна, виробник переїхав у Хмельницьку область,
і виробляється нині цей глиняний посуд у Кам’янці-Подільському.
Денис не мислить локально, а хотів би створити цілу мережу,
покрити й інші регіони Німеччини. Вже готують франшизу, щоб інші українці
чи німці могли відкрити такий самий бізнес.
Працювати на себе та надавати робочі місця іншим.
Денис з колегами першими придумали в Німеччині такий формат
і сподіваються, що все вдасться. А поки на черзі нова партія смакоти…
Це в нас будуть млинці з червоною рибою і сиром. З лососем.
Перехожі на вулиці вже ковтають слину і міркують, що б замовити.
Навіть цей пам’ятник робітнику, що знаходиться неподалік крамниці,
наче теж відчуває запах українських страв
і хотів би скуштувати вареників та млинців.